and now Great Moments and unintended
Consequences part one pros and coins the
year 2008 the problem people aren't
switching to dollar coins even though
they're heavier the solution allow the
general public to purchase the coins at
face value directly from the US Mint and
cover the cost of shipping sounds like a
great idea with the best of intentions
what could possibly go wrong it turns
out people like free stuff and some
credit cards offer Rewards customers
realized they could charge thousands of
dollars worth of coins and then
immediately pay off the balance with
those very same coins earning loads of
free airline miles eventually the mint
caught on changed their rules and block
suspicious buyers from further purchases
but not before many had jacked up their
Reward Points banking free trips around
the world one frequent flyer is even
said to have bought 800 Grand in coins
helping him earn lifetime Platinum Elite
status on American Airlines now that's a
coin trick part to crop drop the year
2021 the problem Sri Lanka's Farms
aren't organic the solution an immediate
Nationwide ban on synthetic fertilizer
and pesticides which coincidentally
saves Sri Lanka $400 million in annual
subsidy costs while they wrestle with a
deep financial crisis oh right maybe
that was the real problem sounds like a
great idea with the best of intentions
what could possibly go wrong turns out
synthetic fertilizer and pesticides
actually work 6 months after the
presidential decree Sri Lanka's biggest
export te was down 18% and R production
plunged 20% forcing the once proudly
self-sufficient country to import rice
at a cost of $450 million due to public
backlash the government was forced to
reverse their ban and pay out hundreds
of millions to compensate Farmers
deepening the country's economic crisis
and Fanning protests that led to the
president's resignation and temporary
exile rice snowa part three wild Mong
goose chase the year 1883 the problem
rats in Hawaii are damaging valuable
sugar crops the solution control the
runs by introducing a new predatory
species the small Indian Mongoose sounds
like let's be honest we all know where
this is going it turns out rats are
generally nocturnal while the small
Indian Mongoose is active during the day
so the two species rarely met lucky for
the Mongo's monges monges whatever lucky
for them Hawaii is full of appetizing
native Wildlife including sea turtle
legs and numerous species of endangered
birds with no natural Predators the
mongus thrived 100 years later they
remain a massive problem on many of the
islands but now hear me out maybe if we
introduce cobras Great Moments in
unintended consequences good intentions
bad results do you have an idea of our
great moment in unintended consequences
put it in the comments below and site
your sources what do we Harvard